normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government there
are cities Across America I remember I
mean Texas there were a couple um I
think Matthew k and a couple other
actors who are trying to push Texas
growing its film industry I mean
obviously Atlanta has like a film
industry right now there are states
across the US that have a film industry
that exists it's just not as big as
Hollywood right so think this was shot
in Birmingham it was a Birmingham crew
Birmingham Alabama shot this and
Birmingham surprisingly is a very
dystopian looking place for a film wow
wow yeah it's just it's got a lot of
rundown buildings a lot of beautiful
architecture there's a scene we needed
beautiful architecture with the rundown
look there's a scene in here like the
climax scene is in this old historic
building uh remind mic Temple yeah but
who spoke there like it Martin Lu K
Martin Luther King spoke there he spoke
at that in that same spot where the
final scenes are he yeah was where he or
where you see him like on the screen
looking at his wife yeah Martin Luther
King Jr spoke there so do you find that
there are a lot of people in the film
industry who are reaching out to you to
say I want to be involved with Angel
Studios but I'm not based in Hollywood
I'm based over here doing whatever like
is it sort of becoming something people
reach out to not just to get their film
made but for their professional careers
yeah yeah yes I mean we can only right
now Angel only accepts um what we call a
torch and this harves back to the
beginning of of crowdfunding so the
Statue of Liberty originally Frederick
bartoldi made a torch he took it around
Europe to raise money he took it around
the US he couldn't get governments to
pay for it so he actually had to
crowdfund the Statue of Liberty right
and back in the day when governments
didn't just cut checks for everything so
every so the French and the American
people saw that torch and they caught
the vision for what he was trying to
create and the same way somebody brings
a torch a video a short film or a full
film if it's going to go to theaters
like sound of freedom and then the guild
looks at it they catch the vision of
where they're trying to head with it and
they vote yay or nay mhm but if I were
like a cameraman and I was based in you
know North Carolina do do you have
people reaching out for those kind of
production type jobs or do you have to
direct them somewhere else so each in
each each production has its own casting
department and uh you know David's being
uh done in South Africa we've got
Productions in the UK David's a film
about King David an an
musical that's coming in 2025 it's a $62
million film that they Crow CRA yeah um
so these are done in different places
The Chosen is shot in both Goan Utah and
just outside of Dallas Texas um uh so
you know and the shift crew it's got the
the guys who did the music for The
Chosen Dan hasseltine and Matt uh
Matthew Nelson Matthew Nelson did it and
it's phenomenal like the score on this
is unlike anything you've ever heard
there's nothing generic about it those
guys did Jars of Clay the band back in
the day they they've scored now the
chosen in this and they're two of the
best movie scores like they're just but
it doesn't sound anything like the
chosen SC it sounds nothing like it then
then you've got um the one of The
Producers is was the editor for sound of
freedom and he also edited Cabrini which
is coming out in March and then so there
is a cross-pollination happening between
the group so like Alejandro monverde who
directed sound of freedom and Cabrini
came in and consulted to help Brock get
to the point where he could pass the
guild right because he was he was trying
to figure out how to get a score up and
Alejandro said well if you did this or
if you did this you know like profal
feedback he gave some really great ideas
or the the creators of Tuttle twins
spent some time on it and so these
different filmmakers join around you
once you've kind of reached this point
where you're where you're building a
film
because they you to suceed as because
it's part of the community but to be
honest to your question Hannah like
we're not replacing the Hollywood craft
like all these Productions they're using
sag actors they're using teams that are
part of the Hollywood uh Network because
Hollywood is better at making movies
than anyone else in the
worldman and they're they're not
ideologically opposed to this well I was
going to say I think it's interesting
because we talk about building culture
and you know movies and I think that's
great and excellent but I would think
all the people that need to make the
film or you know not it's not just the
actors or the people cutting it together
it's also the people holding the mics
and the people with the cameras like
those skills have ties to Hollywood
those guys just love making great art
they don't care if the art is nihilistic
or if it Praises God or if it's in
between somewhere they don't care as
long as it's great art what they don't
like making is campy cringe stuff so
they want something better they don't
want to just make the same five movies
over and over again right to reach the
level that requ Gatekeepers that are the
problem to reach the Lev that's required
for the angel Guild you pretty much have
to have that level of craft which means
you're calling on the resources of the
storytelling world to do that so if
people are interested they have to get
involved in the casting groups and they
have to get involved in acting and work
their way up in the industry and then
they'll have a chance um but what we saw
is that the problem with Hollywood is
that it's become too insular it's become
a bubble and very few people make these
story decisions and then they're they're
they're pushing their views on the world
in the way the stories are told and
because they hold the keys to the gate
those the only stories that get out
those only the stories get out and we're
replacing The Gatekeepers with the
people we're replacing it right at the
same point where it stopped working do
you are you ever concerned that like
having Alejandro come in and advise um
oh his name BR yeah to advise Brock is
going to create a similar problem where
a lot of the genres are it's a similar
genre because a lot of the Interac
activity amongst the artists is going to
except for Brock was already so far down
the road he's more helping him solve
it's like a mechanic saying hey the the
I I can
diagnose the problem with your storyline
that you're facing let me let me give
you the diagnosis and hear a couple of
ideas to solve it and then Brock when
and solved it in his own way right and
and Brock actually like the first time
that the first ideas to try to solve it
actually didn't work but the combination
of those two ideas they got to a
solution and uh but Brock made the final
call on what was on what it was I would
imagine he'd already have the vision
prepared and that he's just doing
technical crafting at that point but you
know yeah there's just it was really in
this case it was probably really mostly
about just
clarifying making sure that the story
came knowled stuff yeah came through
really really clear yeah a lot of you
know your story so well you don't
realize why people exactly when the
writer directs their own work that's a
not a big problem but can pose a big
problem I think George Lucas had that
problem with some of the news the new
episode one for instance is just like a
fantasy in his head I didn't understand
what the point of that movie was to be
honest um at all there was no villain it
was very weird no they're poorly done
villain with Darth Maul so I think
getting the out of the writer's hands or
having an adviser come in that can help
you maybe direct or from the sidelines
be just so you know just cuz you see it
and know it doesn't mean the audience
does what else is coming Cabrini we got
Cabrini coming we've got um there's
actually a slate of eight next year and
we're shooting for 12 in 2025 we're
building a young Washington movie where
that kicks off a it's a movie first
we're doing it with John Irwin who did
uh Jesus Revolution I can only imagine
American Underdog American Underdog he's
the has the most A+ Cinema scores of any
director in Hollywood so John's building
one on the founding of America with
young Washington and his goal is to
release that next year he's got a to
pass the Guild of course but um the idea
is to launch something similar to The
Chosen around the entire founding of
America it's a universe the universe
around the founding of America because
it's not we haven't gone into that very
much I'd love to play Ben Franklin I
don't know if he was fat when he was
young that's wrong you actually got you
could
do
anything take that kite up in the air I
don't know how how deep into George's
life it's going to go that's going to be
really fun then the um so we've got that
one we've got another one called
Homestead that Neil mcdunn is in as well
and it's an end of the world one where
uh every all the power goes out nuclear
bomb hits and they're trying to survive
on a homestead essentially it's it's
based in our time um then there's Bon
Hofer friederick Bon Hoffer famous
Pastor from Germany that fought against
Hitler he was the most famous Pastor in
the country at the time and he he has
one of like his biographies are some of
the best selling books ever and but but
Bon
Hofer goes from pacifist Christian to
saying I will help try to assassinate
the fur fur wow and and the the the the
the difficulty of him trying to figure
out as a Christian as a Christian what
he should be doing and that that film is
that's a big budget one that one we just
signed like a week ago um um there is
David it's a musical it's like Prince of
Egypt cool it's the Old Testament uh the
and it's this beautiful animated movie
for kids and because David was a
musician he wrote the book of Psalms
which is just a book of songs it's
actually like motivated so if you go to
angel.com
timcast and you join the angel Guild you
get a vote on all the different projects
and then you're going to get
complimentary tickets to every single
time we release a theatrical release
and what this does you have 175,000
people right now in the guild but
imagine once you get a million people in
The Guild then let's
say let's say half of them turn up to
theaters you know it's just you
complimentary ticks you tayor Swift tlor
swift every single movie that's how we
change the culture exactly no one can
compete with the point because they're
going to be like they've got it natural
poll are you familiar with the like
what's a venue's natural pole what's a
you so
with you guys having a guild you're like
oh our movies basically guaranteed to
sell out X many seats because of the
amount of people who love our movies
that's right more filmakers come because
there's guaranteed seats and right now
we've got 175,000 which means we're
we're doing a lot of pre-sales but once
we hit a certain point it's Unstoppable
right and you C so when you're joining
the angel Guild you're joining this
movement where you get to pick the
content it's not us we're not the ones
picking it you get to trust whatever
comes out you to trust what comes out
you know it's all going to be good
because the bigger the guild gets the
better it picks thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net